how many balloons do you think it takes
the DreamWorks Fisher kid to get to the
Crescent of the movie five now let's do
six seven said Carroll eight Bill Paxton
said while walking through the law there
was a pause and then Gary said the
unthinkable no and he bellowed the
studio heads were stunned it hadn't been
done before but with luck it just might
work what caused the film to burn look I
worked thirty five-millimeter projection
from 1993 to 2012 and never once did I
have film burned because of an alien
invasion opening your movie with an
object from space making its way to
earth cliche this tiny remote Antarctic
outpost has the capabilities to make a
hamburger with freshly sliced topics I'm
going to guys burgers and lies on this
nonsense HBO's pre promotion of
Westworld ten years before it would
debut is completely out of hand reason
number 473 not to use 3d as a gimmick in
your film no one watching your movie a
decade later will understand why we are
spending five seconds watching a
paddleball come at the screen also we're
supposed to believe this guy cooked a
juicy hamburger set it on the desk and
then wanted to create a visual
representation about boardy was how many
times dr. Davis UFOs don't exist except
they do because UFO doesn't mean alien
spaceship it simply means something
unidentified that is flying Jerry Jerry
hilarious but you also decided to go to
freaking Antarctica there are so many
other jobs that don't require snuggling
up to one of the Earth's ass poles where
you can do just as much nothing as this
supernova this is Red Dwarf we actually
have one code Nimoy so earlier when you
said no one told us what to do did you
forget about the conveniently
automatically connected red phone that
you obviously know you are supposed to
call and give very specific code names
into or a perfect day to Mary Susan
Murphy so I did Susan's friends break
into her house just so that she would
see her husband mention their wedding at
5:00 a.m. why didn't he just tell her to
make sure she watched that's 5 a.m.
nobody's awake at 5 a.m. except
weatherman newspaper carriers and
vampires my little girl welcome to 2009
when computer animators couldn't quite
make humans look realistic so they went
with revolting and creepy instead 30
minutes but Susan just got here and
there was nobody in the parking
there was no passage of time because she
and her father were crying as he
escorted her inside the church and
they're still doing that in the next
scene also the bride arrived 30 minutes
before the ceremony Ruby doesn't know
how to a wedding the Weathermen and the
weatherman's wife somewhere in the
distance Nicholas Cage's ears just
perked up at the possibility of a
weatherman sequel and I will always sin
the perking up of cage ears ah honey my
fingers across how was Susan surprised
by this is this the first time she's
spending with her future in-laws also
what's up with the thumb shaming were we
still okay with disfigurement humor in
2009 is this church near Stonehenge or
something you have to go on a major
pilgrimage to find this place
hell even Stone Edge has roads going by
it considering aliens is right the title
I guess it's only appropriate that they
sent Susan to the Prometheus school of
running away from things
can we just replay what recent pieces
here stop the sound a human would make
while getting hit by an asteroid would
be voice acting also how do we turn our
protagonist into a giant well you have a
meteor slam into her as opposed to just
being exposed to radiation like the kids
in Chronicle that's a long way of saying
she survived this also also this crash
would have caused a lot more damage than
this and furthermore nobody inside the
church even hears this they'd hear a car
accident before they heard this and the
closest car is 35 miles away according
to the movies Church geography
apparently the role of today is wedding
pianist will be played by Voldemort's
mom how the hell did they get all those
mud stains out out when she arrived
there was 30 minutes until the wedding
you couldn't clean those stains out even
in 30 minutes much less the time she had
after getting hit by the meteor Susan's
wedding dress manages to stay intact
during her transformation and look it's
not like I want to see cartoon nudity I
mean you want to see cartoon dude I'm
just asking for some creativity in
keeping with the known laws of fabric
elasticity at the very least just have
the dress grow with her since she was
wearing it when she got strong free
works can never have enough pratfalls in
their animated movies of course the
woman with the undersized thumbs can't
open the chapel doors but why were the
doors even closed Susan came in with the
doors open and no one was there to close
them why are they trying to capture
bridezilla like this she is still a
human being right you could just
actually talk to her even if they don't
they don't even try boy this Monster
Hunter task force sure came prepared for
this exact situation with all the
personnel materials needed to
specifically subdue a human giant
setting aside how they even knew they'd
be dealing with the once' of the giant
here how did they know
anyone would even be struck in the first
place can we talk about the mechanics of
this monster prison an elevator cage
system didn't even make sense in cabin
in the woods let alone here when there
are only five creatures to contain stop
doing that this is clearly his fault
I mean who walks into a room doing
horror movie tropes like this one and
expects not to get hit by a spoon now
they finally did it
they made a character that is literally
too dumb to breathe and if that's the
case I don't even know how they make
cogent sentences Bob is basically the
DreamWorks version of Meatwad why did
the chair that Susan crush go continuity
in an animated movie is still a thing
you know way too boy
what could his boobies like what do
people scream when they see you coming
did you pull out in time possible I may
have misunderstood the question
considering the giant footstep noises in
this humongous door that would have
opened how is it possible that whatever
the hell this is would have been able to
sneak up on Susan also why did they let
it out in the first place if they just
needed to put him back in the name is
general WR monger we should be asking
questions hard questions about what
DreamWorks did was subtleties
bullet-ridden body when they decided to
make these animated features with naming
him Warren have been too subtle for
DreamWorks
character lifting weights lies about the
number of lips he's done to impress
people cliche oh and one other thing the
government has changed your name to
ginormica was there any reason why she
just went through that door
she already met the other monsters so
why did they go through all that trouble
just to tell her the government keeps
monster secret and now we consider you a
monster
and you won't be able to see your family
again it's not like she had to go
through the tour to get to her cell
since all the other monsters came in
through the back door of their cells to
eat lunch
why does ginormica cell have a solid
door here when all the other cells are
glass walls on the Sun it's the movie
prioritizing a series of lame jokes over
logical consistency for shame begin reel
me
sequence is what DreamWorks should have
said when they saw in the finished
product of this movie earlier when Jim
nasty and his girlfriend walked up to
this thing they were eye level while
standing on the ground so why is it now
hundreds of feet in the air
this WT axel F sawn for some time this
design is 100% Stuart the minion and
that just seems despicable to me pummel
all that's happening is your weapons are
just ineffective nobody's dying right
shoot the eye you morons there's
obviously only one scanner to go through
this door but as soon as he gets to it
there's one for his foot sphincter and
both witnesses security is airtight the
continuity not so much awesome as soon
as he clears the door we see many other
people in here so are we to assume each
and every one of them has to do an
asshole scan before entry speaking of
which asshole scan before entry is what
I used to tell my then which button gets
me a latte that would be the other one
sir what idiot designed this thing you
did sir way too many characters were
written with the Seth Rogen jelly
monster character template in this movie
we need a Hail Mary pass
we need raw power weight monsters I
understand where monger is coming from
but after the military blast of the
robot with all the firepower they have
what does he expect monsters to be able
to do especially since three of them are
tiny and one of them is a jelly blob
with no appreciable skills over the last
50 years I have captured monsters on the
rampage in 50 years all you've caught
are four monsters I'm of the opinion
that if monsters exist you'd have run
into way more than four and an extremely
tall Reese Witherspoon we already have
an alien problem general I don't think
we need a monster problem to also movie
shamefully inspire Suicide Squad and
yeah I know the Suicide Squad first
appeared in either 1959 or 1987
depending on what kind of nerd you are
but they didn't even credit John
Ostrander when that movie came out so
I'm gonna stick to my tenuous beliefs
dammit I propose we go forward with your
monsters vs. aliens idea roll credits
jeez who animated this random ground
traffic control lady Marvel in the 80s
has the earth gotten warmer that'd be
great to know that that'd be a very
convenient truth I mean they're
stretching for a joke and then they're
stretching so far for a joke that even
Helen Power and Reed Richards are giving
you side-eye
does anybody have a twenty on
Insectosaurus seriously they left at the
exact same time Gill Arnett would be
excellent at cinema since I just like to
point out that this newspaper flying
around in San Francisco is from
and has New York wins five to one as a
headline followed by a race for the
mayor begins and new campaign finance is
raised I don't know if we can learn much
from that but it feels like a since geez
even in a movie where characters are 50
feet and taller they can't resist
putting a rooftop running scene in the
action can someone tell me why an
intelligence smart enough to travel the
distance of space would design a robot
this clunky and lumbering what is this a
Star Wars movie cars should not work as
skates when less mega roller girl has a
way to put it in neutral and not destroy
the suspension and axles with their
weight these cars would trip her up not
give her an advantage and of course it's
cartoon physics in a ridiculous cartoon
movie but welcome to the channel first
time here why the I entreat skating
toward the Golden Gate Bridge
oh I know it's because of the Golden
Gate Bridge is in some sort of trouble
cliche wait so everybody hasn't gotten
off the bridge yet that almost certainly
means some people have died horrible
deaths but this movie would have you
believe that none of these cars eaten by
the robot or smashed or fell into the
water had anyone in them I'm kind of
wondering how the alien spaceship knows
her name is Susan but I'm even more
wondering why the spaceship isn't
referring to her as ginormica since the
government changed her name to that my
days of running and hiding are over cool
because you are the main villain right
and this is your second tiny scene more
than halfway through so it might be nice
to eventually know who we're rooting
against why would a creature with mostly
human-like Anatomy drink with its ear
and have it spit out of its mouth that's
just being dumb for dumb sake but I
guess sometimes dumb works dumb works
hmm that might be a good name for a
movie company we will think the new
Susan is the cat's meow I'm sorry okay
can we please put a moratorium on saying
I'm sorry after every joke like this
cockroach did it earlier when Susan told
him not to did a maniacal laugh sorry
and right after Susan told monger that
she wasn't a threat to anyone and
smashed a helicopter why isn't
Insectosaurus with him he shows up later
at the party did he just know where to
go without any directions okay I have a
nagging question about her ID number
zero zero zero zero five first congrats
on the optimism of thinking you will
someday have 10,000 monsters and need
all those digits but second and more
importantly so
we learned about the invisible man dying
shouldn't she technically be zero zero
zero zero six did they give her his
number and leave his corpse in that
chair I mean the invisible man
disrespecting this joint is legit that's
my mother you're suffocating her
why isn't she dissolving we saw a
wayward ham simply get lodged into his
body earlier and it instantly went down
like an alka-seltzer plan to cut up a
ragged sack know the way insect asaurus
just appears or disappears as the joke
requires is the same nonsense Soni does
with Bigfoot in the Hotel Transylvania
movies anything that makes me think of
those movies is an automatic five syn
addition all right everyone just stay
calm weren't they basically cool with
the monsters this afternoon when did
they adopt though we need to hide from
them strategy I have an audience that
depends on me for news weather sports
and heartwarming fluff pieces since when
does a news anchor also do weather in
sports did he get a job with UHF channel
just don't see how I can have that with
you Derek who has been nothing but a
one-note dick this whole movie is
probably right but someone who doesn't
want to find creative ways to have sex
with a woman this tall is a terrible
person in my book look I know there are
extremely rare exceptions but in almost
all cases broadcasters west of the
Mississippi start with a letter K and
east start with the W this is not a
difficult thing to get right I know
you're upset Susan but what a dick move
to possibly crush someone's property so
you can take a load off to mope harder
lazy susan is lazy
what's a shindig dear sweet convenient
creator and handiest heaven how did
these three know she was at the random
gas station in the middle of nowhere
right now where they in her pocket
and we're going to find out that their
imaginary the gas station shelter
survives this it even goes back to
normal like it wasn't just sat on and
kicked by a giant woman Pixar's motto is
story is king well dreamworks motto is
there ain't nothing you can't solve with
farts and snot one of my favorite parts
of this movie is how every time susan
wakes up her captor has been able to
taylor swift her perfectly prepared
form-fitting outfit woven to her exact
gigantic dimensions the only thing the
villains in this movie love more than
kidnapping is fashion that's what this
is all about him getting the unobtanium
or whatever out of your body yes that
appears to be correct even though we're
over an hour in and really have no clue
how it relates to anything when Galax ha
requests all the doors to be closed why
do they close one by one many's end
ago when I was but two squiggly alien
speaks English for everything but to
make him sound properly alien he has to
refer to a passage of time as a Zen Tong
for some reason okay ah boy set the
terror level at code Brown cuz I need to
change my pants oh come on Stephen
Colbert not you too did Galax our model
his ship after the fidgets spinner or
did he chop a leg off the old singular
logo general it's targeting us that's
the ideal he can't hold your course
either this guy didn't know what the
plan was this deep into the plan or
monger didn't tell her problem with
riding an army of clones into your plot
is that you begin to look like every
other movie that has a clone army in it
thereby becoming a something of other
movies I may not have a brain gentlemen
but I have an idea cabinet meetings work
this works but I'm not a monster anymore
I'm just me
well except the white hair state anyone
care to explain why everything else
change back but her hair went rogue for
some reason this stupid plan by which
the monsters pretended to be clones
managed to trick not only Galax are but
his computer as well attention but do it
with hand-to-hand combat instead of
those guns I gave you because we still
have 15 minutes to kill in this movie
and of course it's a game of my dancing
monsters that will bring the ship down
because oh I give up this point I'm half
expecting the writer credit on this
monstrosity of a plot to end up being
mad libs
you best entire dance moves are no match
for my security protocols what does the
computer think cockroach has no chance
to break her security code when he is
clearly doing that and will have it
solved by the next few seconds to
self-destruct I can't think of one good
reason why alien ships always have a
self-destruct mode and don't tell me
something like Star Trek did it in
such-and-such a classic episode and
ruled it's a third act crutch to add
more tension to the movie after the
heroes of basically won if the ship is
self-destructing liar doors closing a
possible practical purpose could that
sir she crashed through these walls when
she was what 100 feet tall yet somehow
she still takes up most of that space at
regular height at this size it should
really be much easier than this to
reenter her holes Hey phrasing the only
reason he wouldn't be
as if he was dead or late no way he
could have heard that but I guess
cartoon when in doubt sin it sexist
sorry and you're a butterfly
I'm guessing Insectosaurus was expensive
to animate because he was pretty
worthless for the most part changes into
a moth - ex machina yet another
situation but everywhere else he either
was ineffective or they found ways not
to include him or they just didn't
bother putting him in the scene these
women may not know what a cloaca is yet
but they certainly look overly eager to
find out wowzers I'm so proud of you I
could cry I hadn't lost my tear ducts in
the war well I'm glad this character
didn't turn out to be the movies
secondary villain what the was his
character about it gave him the name WR
monger maybe this was expert
misdirection by a movie that has an ass
identification gag and a code Brown poop
gags I'm conflicted seems a snail fell
into a French nuclear reactor movie sets
up a surefire sequel but what happened
this movie made nearly 381 million
worldwide was 11th place domestically in
2009 and cost a hundred seventy five
million dollars Jesus how did they spend
it on did Reese Witherspoon demand a
giant wardrobe - method voice or
character
[Music]
a man's got to put in overtime for me to
get off space the final frontier these
are the voyages of the starship for our
opening in the garden
and try to take away what other people
have worked for very very hard their
entire lives no didn't bother me at all
you've been letting that quack
experiment on you for over a month we
see that that'll get my hair highlighted